sad news for this Dancing with the Stars  alum former contestant Noah Galloway has  called off his engagement to Jamie Boyd  on Monday the Iraq war veteran announced  the split on Instagram writing after  long and careful consideration we've  decided to end our engagement we love  each other deeply and were confident we  will remain friends while we wanted to  share this with you we appreciate the  respect of our privacy at this time the  time of my life you give that to me and  you know I've got to do this here  because this Noah memorably popped the  question during an episode of the hit  reality competition show hey I was I was  very nervous you know what I was going  to say you know cuz I if I had time  because you know it's like it's in the  middle of a show so you got to get it  done and you're limited on what you can  do there's all those people in there yes  you could have said no that would have  been horrible